[Music]
hello everyone
uh in the previous part of our
discussion we had been
talking about the minor symmetries and
near the
end of the previous lecture i had
mentioned that these minor symmetries
can be utilized to
[Music]
write down the relation between the
stresses and the strains
through this elasticity tensor in a
simpler fashion on a piece of paper
or on a screen using something which is
referred to as the
void notation okay so let's take a look
at
what the what this white mutation is
it's rather useful and it's widely used
so in this void notation the following
mappings are used
so it may sound very mathematical these
mappings are used but
the idea is really quite simple so
whenever we have this kind of a
index pair like 1
1 appearing okay
what we say is that this can be mapped
to just one
similarly when we have the index paired
to two appearing this can be mapped to
just
two just as a shorthand way of writing
okay
so similarly 3 3 can be
mapped to 3
next if we have 2 3
then we have seen that
in the if 2 3 is sitting in the first
two positions
or in the third and fourth position then
within this first two positions it can
be interchanged
so okay
so as part of the first two indices or
as part of the third and fourth place in
the
uh in this the subscripts of this
elasticity tensor
and this thing can be mapped to
or is mapped to 4 in the void notation
next the index pair 1 3
equivalent to 3 1 is mapped to
5 and the index pair
1 2 equivalent to 2 1
is mapped to 6.
please note uh again that when i'm
saying
that these things can be are equivalent
i mean to say that they are equivalent
only as part of the the
the acceptable interchangeability
sitting in the one two places
or the three fourth places okay the
first two places or the third and fourth
place similarly here
only if they are sitting in the first
two places or in the third and fourth
place of the
this uh the elasticity tends that only
then
that is possible okay now with this
knowledge
what can we do what's what uh
what benefit does it afford us so first
of all let's take a look at the
test and set what we have for the stress
sensor is the familiar sigma 1 1
sigma 1 2 sigma 1 3
sigma ah 2 1 we can write but we know
that sigma 2 1 is equal to sigma 1 2 so
we'll just write that as
sigma 1 2 sigma 2 2 ah
sigma 2 3 sigma 1
3 sigma 2 3 sigma 33
this we have written so many times
earlier now
this uh matrix representation
it can be mapped utilizing this
particular mapping
this these all these mappings to a
single column vector i repeat
this three by three matrix
representation it can be mapped
to a single column
matrix okay so it works like this that
this sigma 1 1 goes to sigma 1
okay this sigma 2 2 it goes to the
second
row here this one
to the third place to the third row here
next you note the sigma 2 3
that is mapped to 4 so 2 3 is here
or here so that comes here
next is the sigma the one three or the
three one
which is in this first row third column
or this third row first column
that comes here as sigma five and
finally the sigma one two the sigma one
two here
that comes to sigma 6
so this is the mapping okay
similarly in in exactly the same fashion
uh for the strain tensor also
we have this
epsilon 2 3 epsilon 1 3
epsilon 2 3 epsilon 3 3.
and this can again be written as
epsilon 1 epsilon 2 epsilon 3
where each of these respectively
our map from epsilon 1 1 epsilon 2 2 and
epsilon 3
3 for epsilon 4 4 or epsilon 4
what we are mapping is from this epsilon
2
3
for epsilon 5 we are mapping from
epsilon 1 3
and finally for epsilon 6 we are mapping
from
the epsilon 1 2 so exactly like the
stress tensor
that's it now comes the question of the
elasticity tensor so uh as you can
imagine
uh writing out all the 36 different
components
okay because we have based on the minor
symmetries
only reduce the 81 on different
components to
36 components but even then writing the
36 components would be
well quite a task so let me just give
you a couple of examples
but suppose we have this particular
component c 1 1 2 2 then this gets
mapped to
c 1 2 and just to note
that we are indeed writing in the void
notation
we can put this bar over here okay
so if you want you can go back and put a
bar over here also no problem
okay just to denote that we are indeed
writing in the white notation
similarly here you can put a part bar
over these epsilons no problem
so this is the usual way of writing it
another example
let's say the one two
three three that gets mapped to
uh c
bar this one two is
six okay we can just check quickly here
this
one two is six is getting mapped to six
and this three three is just three
okay so suppose instead we had c
two one three three that would also be
six
bar six three okay no problem there
okay now uh what can we do
uh once we have this okay what is the
real utility
let's just rewrite in the things but
what is the real utility of this
void notation well you see uh writing a
fourth order
tensor in terms in in a matrix form
well it's not possible on a piece of
paper okay it's hard to even imagine it
okay you can imagine a third order
tensor
in the form of a
like a rubik's cube three into three
rubik's cube kind of thing
uh but uh
how do you visualize a fourth order
tensor okay it's difficult
uh there are certain ways of thinking
about it but let's not get into that
right now but uh now that we are
actually dealing with a fourth order
tensor
and this is something real okay the
connection between stress and strain is
something real
and we do want to write it on a piece of
paper in a convenient fashion
so this white notation is what is going
to help us out so you see
because we have managed to write down
these
36 different constants this 36 different
independent components
of the the elasticity tensor
using this alternative void notation
what we can do is
we can actually connect or write down
the relation like this
so as usual we write the rest answer on
the left hand side
i'm still referring to this as the
stress tensor because that is what it is
except written in an alternative or
different fashion
okay whatever i have written in this
form of a
column matrix is still very much the
stress tensor
okay all the six independent components
of stress are here
and this can be written
the elasticity tensor can be written as
a six by six matrix so this is where the
trick
is or this is where the real utility of
the void notation is
okay i again redid it that
we have already seen that based on the
minor symmetries
the elasticity tensor has basically 36
independent components
and those 36 independent commons because
it is 36
it is six square uh we can actually
write them down as a six into six matrix
so you know this will take some effort
but we'll do this at least for once
okay so c one one r uh so writing this
in this way is laborious but it gives us
a clear-cut idea of what is going on
ac one three part the
one four bar c one five bar
or c bar one six
now uh this is very very important it is
extremely important
we might be tempted to write here like c
bar
to 1 but we should not do this okay
okay so we should not write this as c
bar 2 1 and you will see
in a moment why so
this is not a c bar 1 2 yes this is c
bar 2 and this is this is
so these two things are completely
different that's what i want to
emphasize
okay we must be writing this as c
2 1 bar not as c 1 2 bar
ok at least not yet
next this is
proceeding similarly so
let me just quickly complete
so it i must be writing this as c bar 3
1 instead
i should not be writing this as c bar 1
3 just because
we have this thing here we should not be
doing that okay
these are separate things at least right
now
begin the same conduct so
uh i will need another row here so let
me just adjust this a little bit
all right so
let me just add just this bracket a
little bit just to make it look nice
here we go
okay
and this one is just the one column
matrix
uh representing the strain tensor
epsilon one epsilon two epsilon 3
epsilon 4 uh sorry about that
7 5 epsilon 6.
okay again i'm noting that if you want
you can write these
with the bars okay this these strain com
the stress components and the strain
components you can write them as bars
no problem
but you note that in the process of
doing this thing
we have missed out one okay so
as written this relations are not quite
correct
okay so what we are missing
here really is a factor of two in the
stream
uh relations okay so
i'll make this correction here that
maybe i use a different color just to
highlight the fact
that in these strain
relations or in these positions this is
epsilon 3 that's not a problem
but here
i need to have a twice but twice
and it twice here okay so
uh if you can visualize everything in
your head
you will be able to see why this must be
so
or what you can do is you can actually
write this out in
in detail okay and you will see okay
so uh it's it's something like this that
uh when you are actually uh
when you're actually multiplying this
out
okay so you have the contributions
uh from the epsilon
2 3 as well as from the epsilon 3 2.
here also you have the contribution from
the episode 1 3
and epsilon 3 1 so unless you put the 2
here
those are don't get accounted for that's
the issue
okay so now this is correct so i must
remove this
cross sign okay now it is correct
now it is extremely important to note
and as i have been emphasizing here that
this matrix this 6 into 6 matrix
right now okay as of now
it is not symmetric
okay as of now it is not symmetric so
right now we are at the level where we
have only utilized the minor symmetries
so based on that those minor symmetries
we don't have c
1 2 bar is equal to c 2 1 but so please
note here
uh that if
if we were to write that c 1 to bar
is equal to let's put a question mark
here
if we had to write like this then what
it basically means
is that c 1 1 2 2 is equal to
e 2 2 1 1
which basically means in terms of i j k
l is that
you are interchanging the positions of
this i j k l
okay so here you have i j k l
and here you have k l i j we have not
yet
proved we have not even discussed
whether you can do that
okay so that is the that will be the
topic of our
on of the next part of our discussion uh
where we will discuss that
as part of something called the major
symmetries
all right thank you very much
stop the lecture here